AGENCIES A MORE SECURE OPTION
FOLLOWING A BAN ON THE USE OF
CHINESE MADE DRONES.
TONIGHT, HEARING FROM THE TRUCK
DRIVER WHO WAS BRUTALLY BEATEN
OVER THE WEEKEND BY
DEMONSTRATORS IN PORTLAND.
MEANWHILE, PROTESTERS ARE
RENEWING THEIR BATTLES WITH
FEDERAL AGENTS.
CORRESPONDENT DAN SPRINGER HAS
THE LATEST TONIGHT.
>> TONIGHT, PORTLAND POLICE ARE
WONDERING WHERE THE NEXT ATTACK
WILL BE.
LAST NIGHT IT WAS BACK IN THE
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT OFFICE WITH DOZENS
OF FEDERAL OFFICERS INSIDE.
PORTLAND POLICE DECLARED A R RIO
AFTER PROTESTERS STARTED A FIRE
AND BROKE SEVERAL WINDOWS AND
THREW SOFTBALL SIZED ROCKS AT
OFFICERS.
>> WE SHOULD ALL BE CONDEMNING
THE VIOLENCE THAT IS OCCURRING.
>> INCREASINGLY, CALLS FOR
CITIZENS TO RISE UP AND SAY NO
MORE.
POLICE CHIEF CHUCK LAVELLE WROTE
"THE SOLUTION IS IN THE CRITICAL
MASS OF COMMUNITY AND PARTNERS
COMING TOGETHER TO DENOUNCE THE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY AND CALL IT
OUT."
THE FIRST TIME OF THE BRUTAL
BEATING OVER THE WEEKEND, HE IS
SPEAKING OUT SAYING THAT HE
STOPPED TO HELP A TRANSGENDER
WOMAN WHO WAS BEATEN.
BUT THEN THE ASSAILANT TURNS ON
HIM ON HIS GIRLFRIEND.
>> AND TRY TO MAKE SURE HE AND
HER GET IN THE CAR AND THEN BY
THE END OF IT, I JUST
UNCONSCIOUS ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD AND SHE’S TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT HAPPENED TO ME.
>> CALLED RACES DURING THE
ATTACK, POLICE ARE LOOKING FOR
THE MAIN SUSPECT MARQUIS LOVE
WHO POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
HIDING DEFENDING HIS ACTIONS AND
ASKING FOR MONEY.
MARQUIS LOVE HAS AN EXTENSIVE
ARREST RECORD WITH SEVEN
DIFFERENT BOOKINGS AND TWICE HE
WAS CHARGED WITH DOMESTIC
ASSAULT BUT THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY DROPPED THE BOTH OF THE
CASES FOR LACK OF EVIDENCE.
A PROBLEM PORTLAND OFFICIALS